[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que hoy nos
lleva a brasil que conmemora 30 años y
una de las matanzas carcelarias más
recordadas en el país y la región el 2
de octubre de 1992 la policía de sao
paulo reprimió un motín en el pabellón 9
de la casa de detención de esa ciudad un
hecho conocido como la masacre de
carandirú y la cual se saldó con 111
prisioneros muertos este lamentable
suceso ocurrió en vísperas de las
elecciones municipales tres décadas
después la fecha cae de nuevo un domingo
electoral boleto de vuelta regreso a sao
paulo para reconstruir de la mano de un
sobreviviente los hechos que continúan
en la impunidad hasta el día de hoy
nuestro equipo de corresponsales en
brásil visitó el lugar convertido en un
parque para recordar un acontecimiento
que traspasó las fronteras brasileñas y
conmocionó al mundo actualmente brasil
es el tercer país del mundo con la mayor
población carcelaria y el primero en
américa latina'
en diciembre de 2002 tres de los siete
pabellones de la cárcel de carandirú
fueron detonados
hoy en el lugar donde 8500 presos
vivieron hacinados en condiciones de
suman as hay un área verde que lleva el
nombre emblemático del parque de la
juventud
el son de las ruedas de los skates ha
reemplazado las voces de los
presidiarios que estuvieron por años
confinados en la penitenciaria más
famosa de brasil
[Música]
es una historia difícil de olvidar para
quien la vivió en carne propia yo creí
que me iban a arrebatar la vida
principalmente cuando miro a estas fotos
me doy cuenta de que me libre de una
tragedia si me llevaba cinco años en
carandirú cuando ocurrió la masacre fue
condenado por robo y para reducir su
pena escogió trabajar en la limpieza de
la cárcel la rebelión empezó tras un
partido de fútbol entre presos no
estábamos en el final del campeonato yo
incluso había marcado un golpe y de
repente oí el rumor de que había una
rivalidad entre grupos entonces los
agentes penitenciarios nos mandaron
subir a nuestras celdas pero cuando
llegamos la rivalidad ya había cobrado
una proporción más grande
poco después la situación se precipitó
un pelotón de más de 300 policías
invadió el presidio para el motín y la
operación acabó en una matanza cuando
salí a la galería todos estos cadáveres
tirados al suelo esta escena ha sido
constante en mi mente a menudo me
despertaba gritando en pánico
sídney y salió ileso de carandirú sin
embargo al poco tiempo volvió a las
andanzas en
1994 fue baleado mientras practicaba un
atraco a mano armada un trágico suceso
que le dejó en silla de ruedas
a lo largo de tres décadas la policía
del estado de san paulo siempre alegó
legítima defensa para justificar una
ejecución masiva que como asia no brasil
y el mundo
por lo contrario los supervivientes de
la masacre sostienen que ya se habían
rendido cuando las tropas de choque
invadieron la prisión
este perito criminal entró en carandirú
pocas horas después de la masacre para
realizar un informe que se convertiría
en la piedra angular de la acusación
pública cuando llegue para alcanzar el
primer piso tuve que subir una escalera
la escalera en una cascada de sangre la
sangre corría escalera abajo y llegaba
hasta la canilla
en su dossier quedó reflejado que la
policía se excedió en su brutalidad
85 de las 111 víctimas fueron ejecutadas
dentro de sus celdas sin ofrecer
resistencia
cuando salió el auto revelando que todos
los disparos yo diría que el 95% de los
disparos fueron realizados hacia el
interior de las celdas yo no había como
alegar legítima defensa donde estaban
los tiros desde dentro hacia afuera no
había ni uno además fueron aprendidas
armas de los presos sí pero en las armas
que entregamos a los laboratorios no
había vestigio de disparos algunas ni
siquiera funcionaban eran muy viejas
entonces quedó muy claro que nadie había
usado aquellas armas
tras entregar su informe este perito
recibió amenazas anónimas y tuvo que
pedir protección al estado 30 años
después ninguno de los responsables de
la matanza está cumpliendo condena
hoy solo quedan pocos vestigios del
edificio de carandirú en el parque de la
juventud
a finales de 2019 esta muralla fue
declarada patrimonio histórico por el
estado de san paolo
desde hace una década esta jurista está
sumergida en una compleja investigación
para responder a una única pregunta
porque hasta hoy los responsables y los
autores materiales de la matanza no han
sido encarcelados
y
al día siguiente de la masacre ya se
empiezan a borrar las pruebas de lo que
ocurrió allí el 2 de octubre de 1992
porque una masacre ocurrida dentro de
las instituciones del propio estaba
realizada por la propia policía del
estado es algo gravísimo inadmisible
en este parque solo una pequeña placa
hace mención a la masacre es como si las
autoridades hubiesen intentado borrar la
memoria histórica del exterminio la
masacre de carandirú significa una
pésima política de seguridad pública con
niveles muy altos de encarcelamiento y
una policía que mata en vez de gestionar
los problemas sociales de cualquier otra
forma es la policía que más mata del
mundo exactamente
carnero también es sinónimo de impunidad
de los más de 100 policías imputados 74
fueron condenados en 2014 por un jurado
popular pero dos años después el
tribunal de justicia de sant pau lo
anuló todas las condenas en julio de
2021 este mismo tribunal restablece las
penas pero una maraña de recursos
legales impide que esta zaga jurídica
llegue a su fin
aunque los policías sean
responsabilizados lo que es fundamental
es que se ha hecho aún así el desenlace
es muy pequeño delante de la gravedad de
esta masacre de carandirú
[Música]
piqué no de la gravedad de masaje
actualmente ni siquiera ha concluido el
proceso de indemnización a los
familiares de las víctimas ya los presos
heridos durante la operación
mayra que asistió a todas las sesiones
del juicio alerta acerca de otro riesgo
los crímenes pueden prescribir
la masacre de carandirú marcó un antes y
un después en la historia carcelaria de
brasil tras el derribo el gobierno del
estado de sampaolo optó por crear
centros penitenciarios más pequeños y
lejos de la ciudad en un intento de
evitar el hacinamiento
fue un experimento fallido que culminó
con el nacimiento del psc el primer
comando de la capital es la organización
criminal más poderosa de brasil que
controla el narcotráfico y todos los
presidios de san paolo con un ejército
de al menos 20 mil hombres
las asociaciones de familiares de los
presos aseguran que desde la masacre de
carandirú nada ha cambiado
esta mujer habla de una masacre
continuada
hoy tenemos una matanza lenta en
carandirú exterminaron a 111 presos pero
hoy cada 19 horas un preso muere dentro
del sistema carcelario de brasil
entonces se sigue matando esto no paro
pero de otra forma en otros moldes
su hijo está preso por robo ella desea
denunciar las duras condiciones del
centro de reclusión pero teme
represalias por eso nos pide que esconda
mos su rostro
mi hijo hasta hoy como muchos presos
condenados todavía duermen en el suelo
porque no tiene una cama donde dormir
por causa del hacinamiento yo encontré a
mi hijo con depresión dentro del sistema
carcelario la salud de los precios es
muy precaria conseguir una atención
médica demora horas
[Música]
con cerca de 750 mil reclusos brasil
ostenta la tercera población carcelaria
más grande del mundo un tercio fue
detenido en carácter preventivo algo que
empeora el hacinamiento los presidios
brasileños están un
55% por encima de su capacidad
y otros
[Música]
además hay muchos relatos y denuncias de
tortura sistemática contra los presos
deberían trabajar con estas personas
para que puedan salir a la calle y ser
reinsertadas en el mercado de trabajo o
en algo diferente no hay políticas
públicas para las personas que
sobreviven al sistema carcelario
la defensoría pública del estado de san
paolo confirma este escenario en fausto
esta institución realiza 40 inspecciones
por año sin previo aviso y mes tras mes
comprueba que el hacinamiento las
pésimas condiciones sanitarias y la
falta de comida son la regla aquí en el
estado de sao paulo por ejemplo en las
inspecciones hemos comprobado que el 80
por ciento de los centros penitenciarios
racionan el agua hay presidios que
tienen agua sólo dos horas por día de
las 179 cárceles de sao paulo ninguna
tiene un equipo sanitario mínimo
entonces lamentablemente los presos caen
enfermos y falles
la defensoría pública también ha
detectado casos de tortura estructural
tanto física como psicológica casi todos
los días llegan denuncias de agresiones
dentro de los centros penitenciarios
ya registramos muchas imágenes en varias
inspecciones hemos recogido pelotas de
goma y hemos documentado marcas de
bombas lacrimógenas marcas de porrazos
fruto de la acción de los grupos de
intervención rápida dentro de los
presidios de sao paulo
i
[Música]
visitamos una de las 179 unidades
penitenciarias del estado de san paulo
según la defensoría pública el 81 por
ciento sufre de hacinamiento
el director de esta cárcel de máxima
seguridad
destaca que los últimos dos años el
número de presos en el estado de san
paulo bajo un 13 por ciento también
niega que exista una alta tasa de
mortalidad
hay casos de presos que mueren realmente
pero son casos muy graves de personas
que estaban en tratamiento prueba de que
no hay mucha mortalidad fue el control
del cob y que en el sistema
penitenciario la tasa de contaminación y
de muertes aquí dentro del sistema
penitenciario fue mucho menor que en la
calle fue por ejemplo todos los presos
están vacunados
en esta presión hay mil 900 reclusos
850 más de lo que permite su capacidad
430 trabajan para una de las tres
empresas que operan para esta estructura
gracias a programas estatales que
fomentan la reinserción
paradójicamente fabrican ropa y escudos
para las tropas de choque de la policía
y
reciben tres cuartos del salario mínimo
el 25% que sobra es colocado en una
cuenta general que sirve para pagar a
los precios que trabajan para el próximo
miento de la cárcel
[Música]
cuando el estado falla las iglesias
ocupan este vacío institucional para
intentar rehabilitar a un colectivo
estigmatizado de por vida
pero encontramos a sidney en campo limpo
una pequeña ciudad en las afueras de san
paolo después de quedarse tetrapléjico
en un atraco este superviviente de la
masacre de carandirú abrazó la religión
evangélica hoy es pastor y coordina seis
centros de rehabilitación para expresos
toxicómanos y personas sin hogar
si también estuvo muchos años enganchado
a las drogas consiguió dejar atrás un
pasado atormentado en un centro de
rehabilitación como éste hace más de 25
años se dedica a la reinserción de ex
reclusos yo sufrí mucho en mi
resocialización cuando yo salí no tenía
ni un curso profesional
conmigo no hicieron ninguna
resocialización y otra yo era negro semi
analfabeto sin ninguna cualificación
para el mercado de trabajo con
antecedentes penales porque era un
expresidiario y encima superviviente de
la masacre de carandirú las puertas se
cerraron
para ofrecer una alternativa laboral a
otras personas que también fueron
excluidas de la sociedad los centros a
cargo de sydney imparten cursos de
formación profesional de carpintería
peluquería y administración
pones un poco de harina y estiras la
masa así los internos también pueden
aprender la profesión de panadero
y tenía problemas con las drogas y con
la justicia fue cuando yo procuré a
alguien que me ayudase y conocí al
mítico pastor sydney que es un ejemplo
que demuestra que hay solución
en 2019 sydney fue invitado por la
universidad de harvard para hablar del
sistema carcelario brasileño y de su
trabajo con la reinserción de presos y
toxicómanos
para mí aquello fue mucho más que la
realización de un sueño a veces me daba
pellizcos para ver si no estaba soñando
al mismo tiempo que consigo llegar al
nivel de las personas de la clase alta
al día siguiente estoy en la calle
conversando con un mendigo abrazando a
una persona sin hogar vas a aquella
persona que huele a orina lo abrazó lo
besó y le digo que si existe una
oportunidad de oportunidad el ejemplo de
sydney no deja de ser una excepción tres
décadas de guerra contra las drogas han
producido una avalancha de detenciones y
el hacinamiento de las cárceles muchos
expertos coinciden que este es el gran
cáncer del sistema penitenciario
brasileño
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta que nos llevó a brasil
a recordar la masacre de carandirú
recuerde que si quiere ver este y otros
episodios en español puede visitar
nuestra página web france24 puntocom
hasta pronto